NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome
to this episode of UXD
where we're going to talk
about what context is
and why it's critical
to understanding
how people use technology
and how it affects
their expectations
from this technology.
I'm your host Nazmul
Idris, a developer advocate
passionate about
design and mobile.
And I have a very special guest
with me on the show today.
PAUL SAXMAN: Thanks, Nazmul.
I'm Paul Saxman also
developer advocate,
and I love everything about
maps, location-based apps,
and likewise, design.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Excellent.
You're on the right show.
There are few main elements of
context, time, goal, location,
an attitude.
A user's context is driven by
the amount of time a user has
to accomplish a goal, the tasks
that the user needs to perform
to accomplish this goal using
the right different devices
and applications, where the
user is physically located--
are they at home, at
work, at an airport?--
what the user state of mind
is, and are they happy, sad,
stressed, seeking company,
or wanting to be alone.
All these things
put together drive
how people choose
the devices they use
and it also affects
their expectations
from applications
on these devices.
Users have an expectation
from technology
and oftentimes this expectation
is not met my current products.
Sometimes this
dissonance is a result
of creators of
these products not
understanding how small
changes in elements of context
have huge impacts on
user expectations.
So to deliver a
great experience,
you have to ensure that your app
meets the user's expectations
on specific devices
for specific contexts.
To highlight the interplay
between context, device
selection, and
user expectations,
we will give you some
examples of common scenarios
that people encounter
in their daily lives
and how these situations
affect their interaction
with different devices that they
use to perform various tasks.
So let's say you're at
home sitting in your living
room watching "Walking Dead--"
PAUL SAXMAN: Your favorite show.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
Exactly.
--on your TV.
And you see an exotic
location like Atlanta,
and you want to do some research
on vacation spots in that area.
During the commercial
break, you might
pick up your tablet or laptop
and use your favorite travel
app to find vacation
destinations in Atlanta.
Now, since you're home
in a relaxed environment
and are performing a task
that's not really urgent,
you're simultaneously watching
TV and using your laptop
or tablet to do some research.
You're probably also checking
your email and social media
on your smartphone.
People are distracted.
Or let's say you're
at an airport
and you're checking
in for your fight.
You might want your boarding
pass information, what
gate to go to, and real-time
flight status updates
all on your smartphone.
Since you're in an airport
in a stressful environment
and are performing many
tasks that are really urgent,
your intermittently interacting
with your smartphone
and probably not your
laptop or your tablet.
Even though your
attention is split
amongst doing different
things, the short bursts
of interaction that you do
have with your smartphone
are really intense
in this context.
Or let's say you're on the go.
You get hungry.
You might want to find
a place to eat nearby
that meets your
dietary preferences
and maybe even get
recommendations from people you
trust all on your smartphone.
Since you're out and need
to get some food very soon,
you're not really in the mood to
do in-depth research on places
to eat or wait around
to make reservations.
You're not really doing any
researching our planning,
instead you just want to
find the best possible place
to eat nearby on
your smartphone.
Paul, I will hand
it over to you.
PAUL SAXMAN: So
back to this example
of traveling to Atlanta.
You need to do some
research, plan the trip,
and then actually
make the journey
there possibly using
a variety of devices.
So with you as a
user in this example,
let's look in detail
of what context is
and how it impacts the user
expectations and their device
selection.
If you're not in a
rush and you have
time to do planning
and research,
you would probably use a laptop
or tablet to start these task,
but not necessarily
to complete them.
You might choose to
continue these tasks
on different devices
at a later time
or you might choose to restart
the process on the same device.
The key here is that the user
has a lot of time on their hand
to complete the task,
so it's easy for them
to switch between devices.
However, data in the
new multi-screen world
study published by
Google shows that people
tend to use laptops and tablets
over smartphones for research
or planning tasks likely
because of the larger
screens and richer input.
That's not to say you
can ignore smartphones.
About 34% of people
will generally
reach for the device
that's closest to them.
So always keep
smartphones in mind
when building apps
because although it's not
the ideal device
for research tasks,
the user might reach for
them out of convenience.
NAZMUL IDRIS: I do
that all the time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Likewise.
If you're not going to travel
soon in a matter of weeks,
then you would probably want
to book your flights and hotel.
This is going from
research to planning.
Again, you might use a tablet
to start these planning tasks
and complete them on a
laptop or vice versa.
People do tend to use laptops
over tablets for productivity
tasks, such as booking a
flight, hotel, or rental car,
but it's not uncommon
for people to use tablets
for augmenting or
wrapping up planning.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That makes sense.
PAUL SAXMAN: On the
day of your travel,
you might want to get
your boarding pass,
get a taxi to the airport, get
terminal and flight updates,
that type of thing.
These are all types
of tasks that people
tend to do on their smartphones.
It's not likely that you would
want to pull out your laptop
or tablet while picking
up your boarding pass
or finding your way
to the terminal.
Also you'd probably expect
to use your smartphone
to retrieve information
you need when you need it.
Ideally, your smartphone would
make important information
available automatically
without even asking just
like Google Now.
When things are
urgent and you have
lots of tasks to do
that are time sensitive,
people tend to use their
smartphones as a way
to execute tasks rather
than research or plan.
Also in these
situations, people don't
have much patience for
hiccups in the user experience
and is best to provide a
solid and minimal experience
that allows the user to do what
they want quickly and smoothly.
As we saw in the
time examples, a task
can be dependent on
both time and location.
Actually, most of the
aspects of context
are interrelated
somehow, however, each
can have some
independent influence
in how you build an app.
So to ensure that you're
covering all possible user
scenarios, you should try
to consider each variable
independently.
So continuing with
the Atlanta example,
let's look what
happens when we focus
on the task aspect of context.
You're likely to perform
the following tasks possibly
independently in
order to accomplish
your goal of
traveling to Atlanta.
Again, travel
research is something
that you'd probably start weeks
before actually traveling.
During the research
phase, you would likely
try to figure out
what neighborhood you
want to stay in while in
Atlanta and also check out
hotels to book.
For research,
people's expectations
of apps and devices that content
consumption should be painless,
and the amount of
user input is minimal.
In other words, for
supporting research,
an app should be optimized for
content consumption, but not
necessarily content creation.
And again, you might want
to switch back and forth
between these devices to
accomplish these tasks so
be sure to keep user-entered
data like starred hotels
or planning places
to visit on a service
so that it can be
available between sessions
on different devices.
Planning is something
that you might
want to do a week or
two before traveling.
Planning tasks
for travel include
booking flights,
hotels, rental cars.
Your expectations of
an app use for planning
would likely be that content
creation should be effortless
since you might have
to input a lot of data.
So apps optimize
planning, should
allow for easy data entry, and
also easy content consumption.
And again, you might switch back
and forth between these devices
to accomplish this task.
You might want to retrieve
critical data a few days
before traveling,
but you most likely
need access to critical
data the day of traveling.
This includes information
like flight status, hotel
reservations, and
boarding passes,
and other information as you
move from one form of transit
to another until you
reach your destination.
Since you're on the go,
people would use a smartphone
to accomplish all these tasks.
It's highly unlikely that you
would do any of these tasks
on tablets or laptops.
Your expectations of apps that
you're using on smartphones
are quite stringent.
You would want single-handed
navigation, minimal interaction
with the apps to
get your content,
and you would want the app to
actually proactively notify
you of things, of VNotifications
when critical information that
impacts your itinerary changes.
What you're not expecting is
a lot of content consumption
or creation, so the content
has to be presented in a way
that you can consume quickly
without much attention.
Your interactions
with the device
is bursty, short, and intense.
NAZMUL IDRIS: We're
definitely going
to do more episodes on that.
That's a pretty heavy topic.
PAUL SAXMAN: Indeed.
Yeah.
Location, task, and time
are very critical points.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yes.
PAUL SAXMAN: And then
finally, let's look
at what happens when we focus
on location aspect of context.
Depending on what your
physical location is,
what task you would
need to perform,
and the time you had to
perform them changes.
You might perform research
and planning tasks
when you're at home, on
your sofa, or at a desk.
Your time frame for getting
these tasks completed
can vary for many
weeks to research.
Add a few weeks for
planning, your expectations
from apps that you're
using is that you
should have a signed-in
experience where they allow
you to seamlessly
move between devices.
Another expectation you have is
that content consumption should
be easy for research tasks and
some content creation should
be easy for planning tasks.
NAZMUL IDRIS: We're
definitely going
to do a show on the
signed-in experience.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's a whole
other show within itself.
You might be for retrieval
tasks when you're on the go
and your time frame for
getting these tasks completed
can vary from urgent or right
now to some time this week.
User research data
in the study suggests
that people use smartphones
when the urgency is high
and they're on the go.
So you have an
expectation from apps
that you're using
that you should
be aware of current location and
be able to deliver information
to you in uncluttered
manner so you don't have
to spend a lot of
attention on the device.
Another expectation is
that you get notifications
of important things that
will impact your itinerary,
but you don't want to
be overwhelmed with too
many notifications since you're
going to be doing other things
while interacting with your
smartphone in intense bursts.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Just like
the constant interplay
between machine
narcissism and self
awareness for the application.
So again, topics
for other shows.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Now,
let's take a look
at what happens when we focus
on the social aspect of context.
So you've talked a lot about
how time, task, and location has
an impact on what people
expect, and what we're
going to show you is that those
three things come together
and they also drive what
you're expecting out
of your applications
or experiences,
and devices from a
social perspective.
So when you're at
home or at work,
you might want to perform
some research tasks when
you have a lot of
time on your hands.
In this scenario, you
might want to collaborate
with coworkers if the trip
to Atlanta is a business trip
or with family members
if it's a personal trip.
If you're performing
some planning tasks
and have less time on your
hands than you do for research,
then you might want to share
your itinerary with coworkers
or family and find out what
restaurants, for example,
people you know would
recommend in Atlanta
and then actually make
some reservations.
So people tend to use
a tablet or laptop
when doing this sort
of collaboration.
Your expectations
for applications
you're using on
these devices are
that it should be easy to
consume lots of content,
but do a little bit
of content creation.
But the collaboration aspect
is part of content creation,
and the sharing
of information is
part of creation
and consumption,
so basically, you should be
able to do a little bit of both.
Now, when you're on
the go, you might
want to perform some
retrieval tasks.
And many of these
tasks might be urgent.
In this scenario,
you might just want
to get visibility into
others' activities.
For example, you might
want to get commute updates
and see when your coworkers
or family members have arrived
at their destination, or where
they are in transit, and so on.
That would be a really cool app.
The "Multi-screen World"
report suggests that people use
smartphones when doing
this, which makes sense.
However, the other
people in this scenario--
that is your coworkers or
family members or friends--
might be using tablets, or
laptops, or smartphones.
So managing expectations
around social expectations
is really complicated, and
there are so many constituents
that you have to keep
in mind when doing this.
Google Now is a great example.
So if you turn on
commute sharing,
it will notify
people in the circles
that you've chosen to actually
get these updates without you
actually having to do
anything on your smartphone.
They get notifications, and
you just go about your day.
Finally, let's look
at what happens
when we focus on the
mood aspect of context.
Where you are, how much time
you have, and what tasks
you need to perform have a big
impact on your mood or attitude
when performing these
tasks, and again, this
drives your expectations
in a big way.
I know this is complicated,
but it's complicated
because it is complicated.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
the crazy interplay.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yeah.
Exactly.
It's like every little thing
is related to everything else.
So if you're home or at work and
doing research tasks with lots
of time to complete them, then
you might be in a relaxed mood,
you might be lazy, and
open to collaboration.
This drives the
expectations that you
have around what
social experience
you want from the
application and the device
that you're using.
And it also determines
how eager you
are to select the right
device for the task.
For example, you might just
use whatever is closest to you
rather than getting to the right
device, the most appropriate
one for the task at hand.
So you might use a
smartphone that's
close by instead of
picking up a laptop, which
might be in the next
room to do heavy content
consumption or even
content creation.
However, since you're more
relaxed in this context,
you are more willing to put up
with the more constrained form
factor.
Now, if you increase the
urgency in this scenario,
then your motivation
to actually get
the appropriate device
for the task goes way up.
Human beings are complicated.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yes.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Now,
imagine if you're
on the go, the big change
that you have is, in your mood
is that you might
be more stressed,
simply because they're
time constraints.
There's a lot of stimulus
from the external environment.
You could be in an
unfamiliar place.
So already, your
cognitive load is
higher from simply
being outside and not
being in a relaxed
environment like your home,
assuming your home is
a relaxed environment.
Retrieval tasks that you
might want to perform
might be quite urgent, and
this adds to your stress,
and this drives your
expectation from the smartphone
and the apps that
you're using on them.
They need to be accurate, aware
of who you are, and give you
updates that you
need in real time,
and the battery can't
be drained either,
and the location readings
should be accurate.
So even though you might be
using the same application
and device in your living room,
by simply changing your mood
from relaxed to
stressed, it greatly
changes the
expectations you have
from that particular
application and device.
So we encourage you to read this
wonderful research study titled
"The New Multi-screen
World" that
has a lot of information that
provides more insights into how
people use technology.
The report shows us that people
have certain expectations
from tablets and laptops.
However, on
smartphones, they expect
a little bit of everything.
So keep this notion
of context in mind
when you create your
application experiences
on multiple devices.
There are a lot of constraints
that you should be mindful of,
and we've covered some
of them in this episode,
and we'll do more episodes to
cover them in great detail.
And know that if you violate
these constraints, then
you're more likely to deliver
a bad user experience.
I want to thank Paul again
for being on the show.
PAUL SAXMAN: Glad to be here.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thank you
so much for watching,
and see you next time.